what's like outdoorsy stuff you like to
do um I am going on a 3ay through hike
this summer with my older brother either
in Utah cuz I always go to Utah he
really should have sat in the Cody chair
this is a very Cody is okay okay respect
yeah we're like connected like that um
and white guys going through mountains
yeah strong going to the places they
shouldn't go white guys with nice homes
who were like oh it' be so much better
if I didn't have this for 3 Days yeah so
much cooler life is so good how can I
make it hard yeah like I hate having
like AC that I can control via my phone
I want to be outside where it's
uncontrollable I think y'all could use a
little Outdoors okay Outdoors I'm going
to do it hello I tried to invite you and
you denied me so I didn't deny you I
said I'd go would you there's drama here
there's we're about to start fighting
let's be clear sorry this is white guys
in La white guys in the midwest I don't
think they want to ever go outside cuz
they actually battle the elements so
let's be specific they actually fight
them yeah um yeah so what's the drama uh
that's why we brought you here honestly
yeah yeah yeah talk and's like I got to
Hash this [__] out I'm like publicly she
was like yes I'm okay damn okay um no
there's not actually drama like we're a
friend invited us on like oh my God yeah
he's lying you're right he always does
this like I'm sitting here like fighting
for my life like y'all are my like
actual two biggest hops in the world
like this is crazy
the's stirring the pot no please no
please do it please no I'm going to
attempt to go camping for the first time
but it probably like while camping
that's sad well no that that wouldn't be
the first time if I was attempting while
camping let's make that clear okay oh oh
oh oh wow okay um but I'm going to go
camping and don't attempt again while
camping that's sad sorry go ahead go
ahead trying again with this girl who
I'm like friends with and just leaving
her out there be like girl I got to go
girl I got to go like that's an anime
death I can't do this in the snow that's
a cat death in the snow in Canada but
yeah I want to go camping but I'm like I
hate the cold but my friend who loves
camping was like you should come with me
and I have a problem where if somebody
asked me to do something in my face I
have to say Yes um and I just pray for
no followup but there has been
follow-ups and I'm like committed to
going camping it's snow camping like
it's it's crazy like winter ice like
cold is like awful it's horrible I hate
it every time I've done it I've hated it
so that was the drama I was like I was
like I don't know if I want to do that
but then I was like I can't leave my
girls out there alone like I know how to
survive yeah if we get killed it's on
you yeah for real but no the girl India
is going with is like proper like hiker
camper so they're safe without me like
proper into me so she she wants me bad
she wants me bad I'm definitely
going just going to the [__] kid just
your tent every night being like yeah
yeah like just writhing in the comments
yeah she hat
it making accounts for her and
commenting on your own post so you can
screenshot it and look at it yeah
actually real fantasy
[__] oh do you do that like yeah yeah
yeah shout out Tavia you're the girl
Tavia the girl in question call her out
yeah yeah she just she just [__]
squirted at work that's crazy
you just you just unleash something in
her she's sitting at her desk God knows
she's listening to this she's like
listening to us she's like oh my God
those two people who every time they're
around me they talk the most I've ever
heard a human talk I want to hear them
talk more do you have that problem uh
which problem talking too much
dominating conversations yeah I hate it
yeah sucks I I just like feel like I'm
talking too much yeah I don't know not
another the vibe yeah I feel that but I
will never do anything about it so
that's my vibe too like that's never
going to change like what this is just
me yeah I I just have like every few
months I'll think about it and I'm like
oh damn like I just
like destroyed that and he's the queen
of oversharing
yeah not one the camera's on me though
that I'm good at that will shut my
goddamn mouth but I literally meet
someone and be like oh my God like
should we trauma Bond right now that
would be crazy and then they never say
yes and I'm like I'm going to go for it
like is anybody ready right do these
buttons do anything yeah usually oh [__]
am I like [__] stuff up I've been
clicking no those are actually like
those are like letting random um women
listeners know that you're here okay
good so just pinging all of them yeah
just all hello hello hello hello what do
they do are they for like sound yeah
usually like we have sounds and some
other stuff cool a bomb this is what I
wanted to we have like eight of those at
our actually if we had a soundboard I
don't know what the [__] we would put on
there we would put like uh chicken
sandwiches oh think we would do DD Mega
doodo you know DD Mega Doo that's like
we've been on that for the last week
like it goes so hard do you know DD Mega
dooo yeah pull it up literally like
certified
classic like it's so good how old are
you
guys 32
32 I'll be 14 no no I'm 17 hell yeah I'm
too DD
megao to say their final goodbyes to
this Fallen Louisville police officer DD
Mega Doo I'm sorry
moodo I love her I'm I'm sorry I'm like
laughing what's awesome is like her real
name isn't any better mangoo like she
ate how do you say that D howra how she
white with an Indian last
name like I've never seen that last name
in my life
Mendo oh wow oh my God was that polish
no no no dude I don't know but she looks
like she'd be in Terminator like does
that make sense yeah like she looks like
she's about to turn silver with like
really bad CGI yeah okay me talking
about a dead person like that I'm like
ew look at her oh wait I thought we were
talking about the news anchor no I was
talking about
the well the news anchor is actually
looking at you right now yeah I know
she's staring I'm not doing something to
do right at
like we find her name and see if she's
commented anything just completely tuned
us out he's like hey yeah I was like
raising her with my eyes it was rizing
all over her sorry I was just practicing
my RZ yeah yeah sharpening my I need to
clarify I'm not 32 I'm 17 yeah no I'm
I'm turning 18 in March yeah yeah I'm 16
still period yeah yeah Drew's like also
that joke is like fully morphed into
real life cuz he answers it like that
like we were all in the car talking
about our age and we were like I was
like Drew where are you like are you
turning 26 or 25 this year he goes uh no
18 I'm turning 18 and alliv us are just
like okay and he you also still never
clarified but you're turning 26
no
no yeah I'm I'm turning 26 in March oh
boohoo yeah so sad no I just noticed
like my knees hurt your KN hurt now yeah
well I have like gnarly well I mean look
how I'm sitting like there's a reason
why they hurt but um actually I think we
know why anything in your body hurts man
yeah the bungee jump I'm twisted up um
no I had like yeah what is this this is
Fu that's just how he sits it's so weird
yeah it's like natural it feels good
I've like bent my legs so now they're
bow so I've like permanently or like
slowly over time like bent my bones to
like lock into place like this that is
absur also you never just let your legs
rest cuz he'll always sit in the
backseat of a car because he wants to
prop his knees up so he'll spend like an
hour in the car like this and I'm like
that can't be good for your body dude
you're going to die like that um famous
like Pompei lady that they found covered
in Ash wait have I showed you Pompei if
it happened to today did she hit on you
too well you she sent me the craziest
picture no no no Pompei if it happened
today it's like my favorite picture of
all time yeah she's probably sending
this to you yeah that's what I'm saying
like they captured it in time yeah so
stupid but yeah all right can we go yeah
you can B yeah yeah you're done I was
waiting for like the right moment to
like get out of here dip yeah I just got
to go that'd be the funniest [__] ever
you all right we're done yeah we had our
fix we're out of here I need to get out
I got the comments I needed yeah yeah
appreciate your coms do his quick
appearances and make sure he gets a like
head shot from my main camera so he
could see the comments that's why he
goes to anything yeah you got to you got
to do podcast like Club appearances M
this Thursday we got Drew Phillips
showing up it's just a two-minute it's
just me serving [__] on stage like
yeah for three songs worth and then you
bail
damn